YUFEI ZHAO: We're
about to embark
on a new chapter in
this course where
I want to tell you about
Szemeredi's graph regularity
lemma.
Szemeredi's graph
regularity lemma
is a very powerful tool in
modern graph theory, developed
back in the '70s.
Today I want to show you
the statement and the proof
of this graph regularity lemma.
And next time, we'll see how
to apply the lemma for graph
theoretic applications.
And we'll also use it to give
a proof of Roth's theorem.
The idea of Szemeredi's
regularity lemma
is that if you are given
a very large graph, G.
And it's a fairly
robust theorem, so
any large, dense graph.
And here, "dense" means,
let's say, positive x density.
Then it is possible to partition
the vertex set of this graph G
into a bounded number of pieces
So that G looks random-like
between most pairs of parts.
So for instance, I
might produce for you
a partition of the vertex set
into some number of parts.
I'll draw five here.
So you give me a
graph G. I manage
to produce for you
this vertex partition
so that if I look at between
a typical pair of parts,
you see here maybe the edge
density is close to 0.2
but otherwise, the
bipartite graph looks
like a random graph in some
precise sense I will describe
in a bit.
And if you look at
what the graph looks
like between another
pair of parts,
maybe now it's a
different x density.
Maybe it's around 0.4.
And again, looks like a random
graph with that density.
So in some sense,
Szemeredi's regularity lemma
is a universal
structural description
that allows you to approximate
a graph by a bounded amount
of information.
So that's informally the idea.
And you can already
sense that this
can be a very powerful tool.
It doesn't matter
what graph you input.
You apply this lemma, and you
get an approximate structural
or as later on we'll see,
it's also, in some sense,
an analytic description
of the graph.
So the first part
of today's lecture
will develop just a statement
of this regularity lemma.
I'll show you what exactly
do I mean by "random-like."
Well, first let me
give some definitions.
I denote by the
letter e if I input
a pair of vertex sets, x and y.
Here I might, later on,
draw the subscript G
if it's clear that I'm always
talking about some graph
G. So this is
basically the number
of edges between x and y.
And I say "basically"
because even though I
will draw and depict everything
as if x and y are disjoint
sets, and that's the
easiest case to think about,
I'm also going to allow
x and y to overlap,
and also allow x and y to be
the same set, in which case
you should read a definition
as to what this means.
But it's fine to think
of it as disjoint sets.
So you're looking at a
bipartite graph between x and y.
We're also going to look at the
edge density between x and y.
And this is simply the
number of edges divided
by the product of the
sizes of the sets,
so what fraction of the
possible pairs are actual edges.
So from now on, I'll
refer to this quantity
as "edge density."
So now, here's the definition
of what "random-like"
means for the purpose of
Szemeredi's regularity lemma.
So we define a notion of
an epsilon regular pair
to be as follows--
throughout, and later on, I
will omit even saying this--
G will be some graph.
And we're going to be looking
at subsets of vertices of G.
And we say that this pair
of subsets of vertices
is epsilon regular,
again, in G, but later
on I will even drop
saying in G if it's clear
which graph we're working with.
So we say x and y
is epsilon regular
if for all subsets A of X, all
B subsets of Y that are not
too small, so each at least an
epsilon proportion of the sets
that they live in, we find that
the x density between A and B
differs from the x
density between X and X
by no more than epsilon.
Let me draw you a picture.
I have sets A and B. So I have
sets X and Y in my graph G.
And I want to say that the edges
between X and Y are epsilon
regular, so it's random-like,
if the following holds--
that whenever I pick a
subset A in the left set
and a subset B of the
right set, the edge density
between A and B is approximately
the same as the overall edge
density between X and Y.
So in particular, this
bipartite graph, for instance,
is not really dense in
one part and really sparse
in another part.
Somehow the edges are
evenly distributed
in this precise manner.
So that's the definition
of epsilon regular.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: What is the epsilon
for the size of A the same as
epsilon for [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: The
question is here,
why are we using the same
epsilon here, here, and there?
And that's a great question.
So that's mostly
out of convenience.
So you could use
different parameters.
And they do play
somewhat different roles,
but at the end, we'll
generally be looking
at one type of epsilons.
So we just make our life easier.
So you could extend
the definition
by having an epsilon
comma eta, if you like,
but it will not be
necessary for us, and mostly
for simplification.
Any more questions?
All right.
Now if you have a pair x, y
that is not epsilon regular,
I just want to introduce
a piece of terminology.
So you can read from the
definition what it means
to be not epsilon regular.
And sometimes I will
say "epsilon irregular,"
but to be precise, I'll stick
with not epsilon regular.
Then we can exhibit this
A and B that witnesses
the irregularity.
So if x, y is not
epsilon regular, then
their irregularity as, we say
it's "witnessed by" some pair
A in X and B in Y, satisfying--
basically, you read
the definition,
and such that the
density between A and B
differs quite a bit from
the density between X and Y.
So when I say "to exhibit"
or "to witness irregularity,"
that's what I mean.
Now, there's a bit of an
unfortunate nomenclature
in graph theory,
where previously, we
said "irregular graphs" to mean
that every vertex is degree D.
And now we say "epsilon
regular" to mean this.
Sorry about that.
These are both standard,
so usually from context,
it's clear which one is meant.
So this is what it means for
a single pair of vertex sets
to be epsilon regular.
But now I give you a graph.
And I give you a partition
of the vertex set.
So what does it mean
for that partition
to be epsilon regular?
And here's the
second definition.
So an epsilon regular partition,
we say that a partition--
and generally, I
will denote partition
by curly letters such as
that, P. So the partition
will divide a vertex set
into a bunch of subsets.
So we say that that
partition is epsilon regular
if the following is true--
if I sum over all
pairs of irregular
or pairs of vertex sets that
are not epsilon regular,
so over Vi, Vj not
epsilon regular, and sum
over the product of their
sizes, then what I would like
is for the sum to be
at most epsilon times
the number of pairs of
vertices in G. In other words,
a small fraction of
pairs of vertices,
not necessarily edges, but
just pairs of vertices,
lie between pairs
of vertex parts
that are not epsilon regular.
So for instance, if you
do not have epsilon--
if all of your pairs
are epsilon regular,
then the partition
is epsilon regular.
But I do allow a small
number of blemishes.
And that will be necessary.
Just to clarify a
subtle point here,
here I do allow in the
summation i equals to j,
although in practice it
doesn't really matter.
You'll see that it's not really
going to come up as an issue.
And one of the
reasons that it's not
going to come up as
an issue is usually
when we apply this lemma, we're
going to have a lot of parts.
In fact, we can
make sure that there
is a minimum number of parts.
And if none of the parts are too
big, then having i equals to j
contributes very little
to that sum anyway.
In particular, if
all the set sizes
in this partition are
roughly the same--
so if they're all roughly 1 over
k fraction of the entire vertex
set--
then that statement up there
being epsilon regular partition
up to changing this epsilon
is basically the same
as saying that fewer than
epsilon fraction of the pairs
Vi, Vj are not epsilon regular.
And here, if k is
large enough, I
can even let you make
i and j different.
It's not going to affect things
after small changes in epsilon.
So when it comes to-- so
for people who are seeing
Szemeredi's regularity
lemma for the first time--
I think that's maybe all
of you, or most of you--
I don't want you to focus
on the precise statements
so much as the
spirit of the lemma.
Because if you get
too nitty gritty with
is that the same as that
epsilon, you get very confused
very quickly.
So I want you to focus on
the spirit of this lemma.
I will state
everything precisely,
but the idea is that most
pairs are not epsilon regular.
And don't worry too much
about if you are allowed
to take i equals to j or not.
So now we're ready to state
Szemeredi's regularity lemma.
And it says that
for every epsilon,
there exists some constant M
depending only on epsilon such
that every graph has an
epsilon regular partition
into at most M parts.
You give me the
epsilon, for example 1%,
and there exists
some constant such
that every graph has
a 1% regular partition
into a bounded number of parts.
In particular-- and
this is very important,
make sure you
understand this part--
that the number of
parts does not depend
on the size of the graph.
Now, it's true that
for some graphs, maybe
you do need very many parts.
But the number of parts does
not get substantially bigger,
or does not exceed this bound,
even if you look at graphs
that have unbounded size.
So it is really a universal
theorem in the sense
that it's independent of
the size of the graph.
Any questions about the
statement of this theorem?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So in the informal
statement at the beginning,
you said G was a
large, dense graph.
YUFEI ZHAO: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Is the dense condition
appropriate anywhere in here?
YUFEI ZHAO: So the
question is, why did I say
that G is a large, dense graph?
And that's a great question.
And that's because if G had
a sub-linear number of edges,
then I claim that all--
if you look at the definition
of epsilon regular pair,
and your epsilon is a constant,
and if your edge densities
are sub-linear, then
all of these guys,
they are little o of 1.
They go to 0.
So trivially, you will satisfy
the epsilon regular condition.
So if your graph is sparse--
sparse in the sense of having
sub-quadratic number of edges--
then you trivially obtain
epsilon regularity.
And so the theorem
is still true.
It's just not meaningful.
It's just not useful.
But there are settings
where having sparse graphs--
and we'll come back to
this later in the course--
it's important to explore
what happens to sparse graphs.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that M
is independent of G.
YUFEI ZHAO: Yes, M is
independent of G. M depends
only on epsilon.
AUDIENCE: M is really large,
but there's no enough vertices
in the graph.
YUFEI ZHAO: OK,
question is, what
happens when M is very
large, but there are not
enough vertices in the graph?
Well, if your M is a
million, and your graph only
has 1,000 vertices,
what you can do
is have every vertex
be its own part.
Every vertex is its own
part, a singleton partition.
And you can check that
that partition satisfies
the properties.
Every pair is a single edge
and it's epsilon regular.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in the
definition, is it
sort of like all or nothing?
You can either [INAUDIBLE]
epsilon regularity [INAUDIBLE]..
Do you get anything
where if you, like, say,
make this more continuous,
so you allow for it to be--
you quantify how irregular
it is, and then can
you make [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so
my understanding what
you're asking is in the
definition up there,
the sum is--
we put the pair in the sum
of this epsilon regular,
and otherwise don't put it.
Is there some gradual way to
put some measure of irregularity
into that sum?
And there are versions of
regularity lemma that do that,
but they are all,
in spirit, morally
the same as that one there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In the
informal definition,
what does "random-like" mean?
YUFEI ZHAO: So in the
informal definition,
what does "random-like" mean?
This is the formal definition
of what "random-like" means.
So actually later on in the
course, one of the chapters
will explore what
pseudo-random graphs are.
So pseudo-random
graph, in some sense,
means graphs that
are not random,
but behave in some
sense like random.
So "random-like" generally
just means that in some aspect,
in some property, it looks
like a random object.
And this is one way that
something can look like random.
So a random graph
has this property,
but random graphs also
have many other properties
that are not being exhibited
in this definition.
But this is one way that
graph can look like random.
So that's a great question.
And we'll come back to that
topic later in the course.
All of these are
great questions.
So Szemeredi's regularity lemma,
the first time you see it,
it can look somewhat scary.
But I want you to
try to understand
it more conceptually.
So please do ask questions.
Before diving into the proof, I
want to make a few more remarks
about a statement.
It is possible to--
we will prove this version
of the regularity lemma.
But as I mentioned, it is the
spirit of the regularity lemma
that I care more about.
And it's a very
robust statement.
You can add on extra
declarations that somehow
doesn't change the spirit.
And the proof will be
more or less the same,
but for various applications
will be slightly more useful.
So in particular, it
is possible to make
the partition equitable.
And "equitable
partition" sometimes
is also called an
"equipartition," meaning
that it has such that
all the Ai's, all
the Bi's have sizes
differing by at most 1.
So basically, all the parts have
the same size up to at most 1,
because of divisibility.
So let me state a version
of regularity lemma
for equitable partitions.
So for every epsilon
in m, little m0,
there exists a big M
such that every graph
has an epsilon regular equitable
partition of the vertex set
into k parts, where k is
at least little m, so I can
guarantee a minimum
number of parts,
and at most some bounded number.
Again this bound may depend
on your inputs epsilon and m0,
but it does not depend
on the graph itself.
And you see the slightly
stronger conclusion
for many applications
is more convenient,
to use this formulation.
And I will comment on how you
may modify the proof that we'll
see today into one where you
can guarantee equitability.
And you see that for this
m, little m0 too small,
for example, if it's somewhat
larger than 1 over epsilon,
when you look at the definition
of epsilon regular partition,
it suffices to check that
at most epsilon k squared,
epsilon fraction of
the pairs, Vi, Vj
is epsilon regular
over i different
from j, again up to
changing epsilon,
let's say, by a factor of 2.
So all of these
definitions are basically
the same up to small
changes in the parameters.
Next time, we'll see how to
apply the regularity lemma.
And we will apply it
in the first form,
but you see the
second form guarantees
you a somewhat
stronger conclusion,
and sometimes more
convenient to use.
So for example on the
homework problems,
if you wish to use the second
form, then please go ahead.
Just make your life
somewhat easier,
but it essentially
captures all the spirit
of Szemeredi's regularity.
Any questions so far?
I want to explain the idea of
the proof of the regularity
lemma.
And this is a very
important technique
in this area called the
"energy increment argument."
Here's the idea.
We start with some
partition, so for example,
the trivial partition--
and by that I mean you
only have one part.
All the vertices
are in one part.
You're not doing anything
to the vertex set.
It's one gigantic part.
Or if you're looking
at some other variant,
you can easily modify the proof.
So for example, you can also
look at an arbitrary partition
into little m0 parts,
if you wish to have
that as your starting point.
So or I'm saying is that
this proof is fairly robust.
And we're going to
do some iterations.
So as long as your partition
is not epsilon regular,
we will do something to the
partition to move forward.
And what we will do
is look at each pair
of parts in your partition
that's not epsilon regular.
Well, if they're
not epsilon regular,
then I can find
a pair of subsets
which are denoted by
the A's that witnesses
this non regularity, that
witnesses the irregularity.
And we start with
some partition.
So now let us
refine the partition
into a partition
in even more parts
by simultaneously refining
the partition using
all of these Ai, j's that
we found in the step above.
So you start with
some partition.
If it is not regular,
I can chop up
the various parts in some way.
So I start with some
partition over here.
And what we are going to do is,
let's say between these two,
it's not epsilon
regular, so I can
find some pairs of vertex sets
that exhibits the irregularity.
I chop it up.
And I can keep further chopping
up the rest of the parts.
If these two parts are
not epsilon regular,
then I chop it up like that.
And I can keep on doing it.
And originally, I
have three parts.
Now I have 12 parts.
And this is a refined partition.
And now I repeat
until I am done.
I am done when I
obtain a partition that
is epsilon regular.
Now, the basic question when
it comes to the strategy
is, are you ever
going to be done?
When are you going to be done?
And if this process
goes on forever
or goes on for a very
long time, then you
might have a lot of parts.
But we want to
guarantee that there
is a bounded number of parts.
So what we will show is that--
to show that you have a
small number of parts,
in other words, why does
this process even stop--
and in particular,
we want it to stop
after a small number of
steps, after a bounded number
of steps.
And to do this, we will
define some notion called
an "energy" of a partition.
And this energy will increase.
So first of all, the
energy is some quantity
that we'll define that
lies between 0 and 1.
It's some real number
lying between 0 and 1.
And each step, the energy goes
up by some specific quantity.
Therefore, because the energy
cannot increase past 1,
this iteration stops after
a bounded number of steps.
And once it's done,
we end up with
a epsilon regular partition.
So that's the basic strategy.
And what I want to show you is
how to execute that strategy.
Any questions so far?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just to clarify
[INAUDIBLE] a bit,
if some Vi's into non-epsilon
regular partitions,
is it possible for Ai,j and
Aik to overlap somehow, right?
Just kind of make those
into three partitions?
YUFEI ZHAO: So if I
understand correctly,
you are worried about
between different pairs,
you might have interactions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
YUFEI ZHAO: So you
have seen the proof,
but I think this is actually
a very important and somewhat
subtle point, is that I do
not refine at each step,
I find a pair of
witnessing sets.
I find all of these witnessing
sets all at the same time,
and I refine
everything all at once.
AUDIENCE: OK, so
it's like if you do
have overlap between two
witnessing sets, that's OK?
YUFEI ZHAO: That is OK,
because this step doesn't care.
If you have two witnessing
sets that overlap, that is OK.
We'll see the proof.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you
just find one pair
of witnessing sets
for each Vi, Vj,
even though there might be more?
YUFEI ZHAO: Question
is, do we find
just one pair of
witnessing sets even
though there could be more?
And the answer is, yes.
We just need to find one.
There could be lots.
So if it's not
epsilon regular, it
might be very not
epsilon regular.
And in fact, being a witnessing
set is a fairly robust notion.
If you just take out a
small number of vertices,
it's still a witnessing set.
Any more questions?
Great.
So let's take a quick break
and then we'll see the proof.
Let's get started with the
proof of Szemeredi's regularity
lemma.
And to do the proof,
I want to develop
this notion of energy which
you saw in the proof sketch.
So what do I mean by "energy?"
First, if I-- let me
define some quantities.
If I have two vertex
subsets, U and W,
let me define this quantity,
q, which is basically
the edge density squared.
But I normalize it
somewhat according
to how big U and W are.
I'm going to use the
letter and N to denote
the number of vertices in
G. So this is some cube.
And for partitions, if I
have a pair of partitions,
Pu of U into k parts, and the
partition Pw of W into l parts,
I set this q of Pu and Pw to be
the quantity where I sum over
basically all pairs,
one part from U,
one part from W of this
q between Ui and Wj.
So this is the density squared.
And I'm taking some
kind of weighted average
of the squared density.
So here is a weighted average.
If you prefer to think
about the special case
where this partition
is an equipartition,
then it is really the average
of these squared densities.
It's a mean square density.
And finally, for a partition
P of the vertex set of G
into m parts, we define
this q of this partition P
to be q of P with
itself according
to the previous definition.
Or in other words, I do this
double sum, i from 1 to m,
j from 1 to m, q of Vi, Vj.
And this is the quantity
that I will call
the "energy" of the partition.
It is a mean squared
density, some weighted mean
of the edge densities
between pairs
of parts in the partition.
You might ask, why is
it called an energy?
So you might see from
this formula here,
it's some kind of a
mean square density,
so it's some kind of
an average of squares.
So in particular, it's some
kind of an L2 quantity.
And there's a general
phenomenon in mathematics,
I think borrowed from
physical intuitions,
that you can pretty much
call anything that's
an L2 quantity an energy.
And so that's, I think,
where the name comes from.
So this is the important
object for our proof.
And let's see how to execute a
strategy, the energy increment
argument outlined on
the board over there.
So we want to show that you
can refine a partition that
is not epsilon regular in such
a way that the energy goes up.
And to do that, let me
state a few lemmas regarding
the energy of a partition
under refinement.
And the point of the
next several lemmas
is that the energy never
decreases under refinement,
and it sometimes increases
if your partition is not
epsilon regular.
So the first lemma
is that if you
look at the energy between
a pair of partitions,
it is never less than the energy
between the two vertex sets.
So for instance, if you
have U and W like that,
and I partition
them into Pu and Pw,
and I measure the
energy, just basically
the squared density between
U and V versus summing up
the individual squared
densities after the partition,
the left side is always at least
as great as the right side.
So this is really a claim.
It's a fairly simple
claim about convexity,
but let me set it up
in a way that will
help some of the later proofs.
So let me define a
random variable, which
I call Z, in the following way.
So here's a process
that I will use
to define this random variable.
I will select x, little x, to
be a vertex uniformly chosen
from U, from the
left vertex set.
And I will select a vertex
y uniformly chosen from W.
x and y, they fall into
some part in the partition.
So suppose Ui is
the part where x i
falls, and Wi is the set in
the partition where y falls.
So Ui is a member
of this partition.
Wi is a member of the
other partition of W.
Then I define my
random variable Z
to be the x density
between Ui and Wj.
So it's Wj.
So that's the definition.
So pick x randomly.
Pick y randomly.
Suppose x falls in Ui.
Suppose y falls in Uj.
Then Z is the x density
between these two parts.
So Z is some random variable.
Let's look at properties
of this random variable.
First, what is this,
it's expectation?
It's a discrete random variable.
And you can easily compute
all of these quantities
by just summing up according
to how Z is generated.
So I look overall, i and j.
What's the probability
that x falls in Ui?
It is the size of Ui
as a fraction of U.
What's the probability
that y falls in Wj?
It's the size of Wj as
a fraction of size W.
And then Z is this
quantity here.
So this is what I find to
be the expectation of Z.
But you see the density
multiplied by the product
of the vertex set sizes,
that's just the number of edges
between U and W. And you
sum over all the i, j's.
So that, which is simply the
edge density between U and W.
So that's the expectation
of the Z variable.
On the other hand,
what's the second moment?
In other words, what's the
expectation of the square of Z?
Again, we do the
same computation.
First part is the same.
The second part now
becomes a d squared.
And look at how
we define energy.
This quantity here is
basically the energy q
between the partition U
and the partition of W,
except there's normalization.
That's not quite the same
as the one we used before.
So we will just put
in that normalization.
So now you compare
the expectation
of Z versus the
expectation of Z squared.
And we know by convexity that
the expectation of Z squared
is at least as large as
the expectation of Z,
that quantity squared.
But if you plug in what values
you get for these two guys,
you derive the inequality
claimed in Lemma 1.
You have to cancel some
normalization factors,
but that's easy to do.
So that's the first lemma.
So the first one is just
about a pair of parts,
and identify
partition, each part,
what happens to the
energy between this pair.
And the second one is a direct
corollary of the first one.
It says that if you
have a second partition,
P prime that refines P, then the
energy of the second partition,
the refinement, is never
less than the energy
of the first partition.
And it is a direct consequence
of the first lemma,
because we simply apply this
lemma to every pair of parts
in P. Between every
pair of parts,
the energy can never go down.
So overall, the energy
does not go down.
And finally, so far, we've just
said that the partitions can
never make the energy go down.
But in order to
do this proof, we
need to show that the
energy sometimes goes up.
And that's the point
of the third lemma.
The third Lemma tells us that
you can get an energy boost.
So this is the Red Bull Lemma.
You can get an energy boost
if you are feeling irregular.
So if U, W is not
epsilon regular,
and this epsilon regularity
is witnessed by U1 in U and W1
in W, then I claim that the
energy obtained by chopping U
into U1 and its
complement against W1,
against the complement of W1
and W, so here again U and W,
I find a witnessing set
for their irregularity.
And now I partition left
and right according to--
chop each part into two.
So this energy
between this partition
into two on both sides is
bigger than the original energy
plus something
where we can gain.
And this something where
we can gain turns out
to be at least epsilon
raised to the power
4 times the size of U, size
of W, divided by n squared.
Can you prove it?
Let's define Z the same
as in the previous proof,
as in the proof of Lemma 1.
In Lemma 1, we just used the
fact that the L2 norm of Z,
the expectation of the
square, is at least
the square of the expectation.
But actually, there
are differences in it.
It's called a "variance."
The variance of Z
is the difference
between these two quantities.
I know that it's
always non-negative.
So if you look at how we
derived the expectation of Z
and expectation of Z
squared, you immediately
see that its
variance we can write
as, up to a normalizing
factor, the difference
between this energy on one hand
and the energy between U and W,
namely the mean square
of the normalization.
On the other hand, a different
way to calculate the variance
is that it is equal to the
expectation of the deviation
from the mean squared.
So let's think about the
deviation from the mean.
I am choosing a random
vector in, on the left, U,
and another random point,
random vertex on the left,
and a random point on the right.
In the event that they
both lie in the sets
that witness the
irregularity, so in the event
where x falls here
and y falls here,
which occurs with
this probability,
see that this quantity here is
equal to the density between U1
and W1 minus the density--
and this expectation
of Z is just
the density between U and W. So
interpreting this expectation
for what happens
when x falls in U1
and when y falls in W1,
ignoring all the other events,
because the quantity is always
non-negative everywhere.
But now from the definition
of epsilon regularity,
or rather the witnessing
of epsilon irregularity,
you see that this U1 is at least
an epsilon fraction of U. W1's
at least an epsilon
fraction of W.
And this final quantity here
is at least epsilon inside, so
at least epsilon squared.
So here we're using all
the different components
of the definition
of epsilon regular.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What happens if we're
dividing with more witnessing
sets?
YUFEI ZHAO: So
you're asking what
happens if we divide with
more witnessing sets?
So hold onto that thought.
So right now, I'm just
showing what happens
if you have one witnessing set.
Any more questions?
So here we have
epsilon to the 4th.
And if you're putting
the normalization
comparing these two
interpretations,
you'll find the inequality
claimed by the lemma.
So now we are ready to show
the key part of this iteration.
I'll show you precisely how
this iteration works, and show
that you always get an energy
boost in the overall partition.
So I'll call the
next one Lemma 4.
And this says that if you have
a partition P of the vertex set
of G into k parts, if this
partition is not epsilon
regular, then there exists a
refinement called Q where every
part V sub i is partitioned
further into at most 2 the k
parts, and such that
the partition of Q--
so the energy of the
new partition Q--
increases substantially from
the previous partition P.
And we'll show that
you can increase
by at least epsilon
to the 5th power,
some constant in epsilon.
So if you look at the
strategy up there,
if you can do this
every step, then that
means that the
number of iterations
is bounded by 1 over
epsilon to the 5th power.
So to prove this lemma here,
we will use the three lemmas
up there and put them together.
So for all the pairs
i, j such that V sub i,
V sub j is not epsilon
regular, as outlined
in the proof in the
outline up there,
we will find this A
superscript i, j in Vi,
and A superscript j, i in Vj
that witness the irregularity.
So do this simultaneously
for all pairs i, comma, j,
where the Vi, Vj is
not epsilon regular.
Now what we're going to define
Q as is the common refinement.
So take all of,
just as indicated
in that picture up
there, simultaneously
take all of these A's and use
them to refine P. Starting
with P, starting with
a partition you have,
simultaneously cut
everything up using
all of these witnessing sets.
Now, we only have
witnessing pairs for pairs
that are not epsilon regular.
If they're epsilon regular,
you don't worry about them.
One of the claims in
the lemma now is--
this is the Q that
we'll end up with.
We'll show that this
Q has that property.
So one of the
claims in the lemma
is that every Vi is partitioned
into at most 2 to the k parts.
So I hope that part is
clear, because how are we
doing the refinement?
We're taking Vi.
It's divided into
parts using these A i,
j's, one j coming from each
pair that is irregular with Vi.
So I'm cutting up Vi
using at most k sets,
so one coming from each
of the other possible.
Maybe fewer than k-- that's
fine-- but at most k sets
are used to cut up each Vi.
So you have at most
2 to the k parts
once you cut everything up.
But the tricky part is to show
that you get an energy boost.
So let's do this.
How do we show that you
get an energy boost?
We're going to put the
top three lemmas together.
First, we want to
analyze the energy of Q.
So let's write it out.
So the energy of Q is the sum
over this energy of individual
partitions of the Vi's.
And by this P sub Vi, P sub
Vj, I mean the partition of Vj
given by Q. So what happens
after you cut up the Vi--
that's what I mean by P sub
Vj, or rather I should call it
Q sub Vi, Q sub Vj.
By Lemma 2, we find that--
so let me separate
them into two cases.
The first case sums
over i, j such that Vi,
Vj is epsilon regular.
And by Lemma 1, so here
we're using Lemma 1,
we find that this quantity
here cannot be less than the Q
of Vi, Vj.
So take those two parts.
Before and after
the refinement by Q,
the energy cannot go down.
So I don't worry too much about
pairs that are epsilon regular.
But no let me look up here
that are not epsilon regular.
So what we will do
now is even though--
so let's look at that
picture up there.
So let's focus on
what I drew in red.
So let's focus between 1 and 2.
So suppose the shaded part
is the witnessing sets.
The witnessing sets
got cut up further
by other witnessing sets.
But I don't have to worry about
them because Lemma 2 or Lemma
1, really, tells me that I
can do an inequality where
I go down to just comparing the
energy between this partition
of two parts, this
single witnessing set
and its complement, versus
what happens in its partner.
So in other words, over
here, the Q of this pair,
I am saying that it is
no less than if I just
look at what happens if you
only cut up these two sets using
the red lines.
Let's go on.
Applying Lemma 3, the
energy boost lemma,
the first part stays the same.
So this first part
stays the same.
And the second part,
now, because I'm
looking at witnessing
sets for irregularity,
I get this extra boost.
So this goes back to one of
the questions asked earlier,
where in Lemma 3, I don't have
to now worry about what happens
if you have further cuts,
because I only need to worry
about the case where I
only have a single cut
between the epsilon
irregular pairs.
So putting it together, we
see that the previous line
is at least, if you sum over
the Q's of all the pairs
plus this extra epsilon to
the 4th term for all pairs
that are not epsilon regular.
I'm applying monotonicity
of energy for the types,
for pairs that are
epsilon regular,
an energy boost for pairs
that are not epsilon regular.
And for the latter type,
I obtain this boost.
Now remember what's the
definition of an "epsilon
regular partition."
Unfortunately, it's no
longer on the board,
but it says that
this sum over here,
if it is an epsilon
regular partition,
it is at most epsilon.
So if it is not epsilon
regular, we can lower bound it.
And that's indeed
what we will do.
The first sum here
is, by definition,
Q of the partition P.
And the second sum,
by the definition
of epsilon regular,
is at least epsilon
to the power 5.
So here we're using
the definition
of epsilon regular
partition, namely,
that a large fraction,
so at least an epsilon
fraction, basically,
of pairs of vertex sets
are not epsilon regular,
but in this weighted sense.
And that finishes the
proof of Lemma 4 up there.
Any questions so far?
All right, so now we are
ready to finish everything
off, and prove Szemeredi's
regularity lemma.
So let's prove Szemeredi's
Let's start with the
trivial partition,
meaning just one large part.
And we are going
to repeatedly apply
Lemma 4 whenever the
partition at hand
is not regular, whenever
the current partition is not
epsilon regular.
So let's look at its energy.
The energy of this partition--
so this is a weighted mean
of the edge density squared,
so it always lies
between 0 and 1,
just from the
definition of energy.
On the other hand,
Lemma 4 tells us
that the energy increases by at
least epsilon to the 5th power
at each iteration.
So this process cannot
continue forever.
So it must stop after at most
epsilon to the minus 5th power
number of steps.
And when we stop, we must
result in an epsilon regular
partition, because
otherwise, you're
going to continue applying the
lemma and push it even further.
And that's it.
So that proves Szemeredi's
graph regularity lemma.
Question.
AUDIENCE: It's going to be
some really big value of M.
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, let's
talk about bounds.
So let's talk about
how many parts.
So how many parts does
this proof produce?
We can figure it out.
So we have some number of steps.
Each step increases the
number of parts by something.
So if P has k parts,
so then Lemma 4 refines
P into at most how many parts?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the k
YUFEI ZHAO: Yeah, so
k times 2 to the k.
And I have many
iterations of this guy.
So some of you are
already laughing,
because it's going to
be a very large number.
In fact, because it's
going to be so large,
it makes my calculations
slightly more convenient.
It really doesn't
change the answer
so much if I just bound k to
the 2 to the k by 2 to the 2
to the k.
So the final number of
parts is this function
iterated on itself epsilon
to the minus 5 times.
So it's a power of 2 of height
at most 2 to the epsilon
to the 5.
It's a finite number, so it
depends only on epsilon and not
on the size of your graph.
And this is the most
important thing.
It does not depend on
the size of your graph.
It is quite large.
In fact, even for reasonable
values of epsilon,
like 1% or even 10%, this
number is astronomically large.
And you may ask is
it really necessary,
because we did this proof, and
it came out fairly elegantly,
I would say it, how
the proof was set up.
And you arrived at
this finite bound.
But maybe there's
a better proof.
Maybe you can work harder and
obtain somewhat better bounds.
So you can ask, is it possible
that the truth is really
somehow much smaller?
And the answer
turns out to be no.
So there is a
theorem by Tim Gowers
which says that there
exists some constant.
The precise statement,
again, is not so important,
but based on what I just said,
you cannot improve this bound
given by this proof.
So for every epsilon
small enough,
there exists a graph whose
epsilon regular partition
requires how many parts?
So the number of parts at
least this tower of 2 of height
some epsilon to the minus c.
So really it's a tower
of exponentials of size,
essentially polynomial
in 1 over epsilon.
So maybe you can squeeze
the 5 to something less.
Actually, we don't even
know if that's the case,
but certainly you cannot do
substantially better than what
the proof gives.
So Szemeredi's regularity lemma
is an extremely powerful tool.
And we'll see applications
that are basically
very difficult to prove.
And for some of
these applications,
we don't really
know other proofs
except using Szemeredi's
regularity lemma.
But on the other hand, it gives
terrible quantitative bounds.
So there is a lot of
interest in combinatorics
where once you see a proof that
requires Szemeredi's regularity
lemma, or that is first
proved using this technique,
to ask can it be used
using some other technique?
In fact, Szemeredi himself has
worked a lot in that direction,
trying to get rid of
the uses of his lemma.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: How could you
modify it for equipartitions?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, great.
Question is, how can we
modify it for equipartitions?
So let's talk about that.
So it's a fantastic question.
So look at this proof
and see what can we
do if we really want
all the parts to have
roughly the same size, let's
say differing by at most 1.
So how to make the epsilon
regular partition equitable?
Any guesses?
Any attempts on what we can do?
I mean, basically it's
going to follow this proof.
As I said, the spirit of
Szemeredi's regularity lemma
is what I've shown you.
But the details and
executions may vary somewhat
depending on the specific
purpose you have in mind.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can we just add--
[INAUDIBLE] add things
to the smaller part
because we know
that-- by the fact
that it's not [INAUDIBLE]
that parts aren't too small?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so you're saying
we're going to add something
or to massage the partition
to make it epsilon--
AUDIENCE: Add vertices to the
smaller parts of the partition.
YUFEI ZHAO: Add vertices to the
smaller parts of the partition,
now when are you
going to do that?
AUDIENCE: When they're-- like
so you do the refinement,
then when they're
not [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: So you
want to do this
at every stage of the process.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: I like that idea.
So here's what
we're going to do.
So we still run
the same process.
So we're going to have this P,
which is the current partition.
So I have current partition.
And as before, we
initially have it
as either the trivial
partition, if you like,
or m arbitrary equitable parts.
Start with something
where you don't really
care about anything
except for the size.
And you run basically
the same proof,
where if your P is
not epsilon regular,
then do what we've done
before, so basically
exactly the same thing.
We refine P using pairs
witnessing regularity,
same as the proof
that we just did.
And now we need to do
something a little bit more
to obtain equitability.
And what we will
do is right after--
so each step in iteration, right
after we do this refinement,
so after we cut up our graph
where maybe some of the parts
are really tiny, let's massage
the partitions somewhat
to make them equitable.
And to make our life
a little bit easier,
we can refine the
partition somewhat further
to chop it up into somewhat
smaller resolution.
And this part, you
can really do it
either arbitrarily or randomly.
Some ways may be slightly
easier to execute,
but it doesn't really
matter how you do it.
It's fairly robust.
You refine it further.
And basically, I want
to make it equitable.
Sometimes, you can just
do that by refining,
but maybe if you have
some really small parts,
then you might need to
move some vertices around,
so I call that "rebalancing."
So move and merge some vertices,
but only a very small number
of vertices, to make equitable.
So you run this loop until you
find that your partition is
epsilon regular.
Then you're done.
Whenever you run this
loop, because we're
doing the second
step, your partition
is always going to be equitable.
But we now need to
control the energy again
to limit the number of steps.
And the point here is
that the first part still
is exactly the same as before,
where the energy goes up
by at least epsilon
to the minus 5.
But the second part, the
energy might go down,
because we're no longer
refining, just refining.
Because we're doing
some rebalancing.
But you can do it in such a way
that the amount of rebalancing
that you do is really small.
You're not actually changing
the energy by so much.
So I'll just hand
wave here, and say
that we can do this in such
a way where the energy might
go down, but only a little bit.
So you're only changing
a very small number
of vertices, very small
fraction of vertices.
So if you change only an
epsilon fraction of vertices,
you don't expect
the energy, which
is something that comes out of
summing pairs of vertex parts,
to change by all that much.
So putting these
two together, you
see that the energy still goes
up by, let's say, at least 1/2
of epsilon to the 5th power.
And so then, the rest of the
proof runs the same as before.
You finish in some
bounded number of steps.
And you result in an
equitable partition
that's epsilon regular.
I don't want to
belabor the details.
I mean, here, there's
some things to check,
but it's, I think,
fairly routine.
It's is more of an exercise
in technical details.
But the thing that actually
is somewhat important
is there's a wrong
way to do this.
I just want to point out
that what's the wrong way
to do this, is that you
apply regularity lemma,
and you think now
it has something
that's epsilon regular.
Then I massage it to try to
make it equitable at the end.
And so if I don't
look into the proof,
I just look at a statement of
Szemeredi's regularity lemma,
and I get something
that's epsilon regular,
I say I'm just going to
divide things up a little
bit further, that doesn't work.
Because the property
of being epsilon
regular is actually not
preserved under refinement.
So look at the definition.
You have something
that's epsilon regular.
You refine the partition.
If might fail to
be epsilon regular.
So you really have to take into
the proof to get equitability.
So just to repeat, a wrong
way to try to get equitability
is to apply regularity
lemma, and at the end,
try to massage it
to get equitable.
That doesn't work.
Next time, I will show you how
to apply Szemeredi's regularity
lemma.